[MUSIC PLAYING]
HEATHER CROSS: Hi, there.
Heather here.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: And hello
again from me, Priyanka,
a customer engineer
here at Google.
On today's episode, we'll be
discussing Deployment Manager.
As our customers use
Cloud in bigger ways,
it's becoming
increasingly important
to simplify Cloud management.
Deployment Manager is an
infrastructure deployment
service that
automates the creation
and management of Google
Cloud Platform resources.
HEATHER CROSS: That's right.
And we'll also run
through a quick demo
of the self-paced
lab, where we'll
use Deployment Manager to create
a simple configuration file,
use that file to
create a deployment,
then view the deployment
information on a manifest.
So let's walk through how
Deployment Manager helps
simplify Cloud management.
I like to think of
Deployment Manager
as a cookbook combining all
the recipes into one place.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Exactly.
And think of each
resource as a recipe.
I like the fact that
Deployment Manager
supports a repeatable
deployment process.
By creating configuration files,
which define the resources,
the process can be
repeated over and over
with consistent results.
HEATHER CROSS: And keep in
mind declarative language
can be used in creating
those configuration files.
I can say exactly what I
want the configuration to be,
and I just let the system
figure out what steps to take.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Absolutely.
Configurations can
get really complex.
A basic configuration file might
be enough for simple workloads,
but for more complex
architectures
and configurations
that you plan to reuse,
you can break your
configuration into templates.
Templates allow you to
separate your configuration out
into different pieces
that you can reuse
across different deployments.
HEATHER CROSS:
Deployment Manager
allows you to easily
deploy systems
in a variety of
locations and provides
control needed to easily
roll out new services.
It also gives you
the flexibility
to deploy several versions
of your code simultaneously.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
It also allows
you to change a deployment
by adding or removing
resources, and
updating properties
of existing resources.
Qwiklabs time.
In this lab, you will use
the gcloud Command-Line tool
to create a simple
configuration file.
Use that file to
create a deployment.
Then view deployment
information in a manifest.
HEATHER CROSS: You
can check out the link
to start the Qwiklab here.
Keep in mind that this will take
about 30 minutes to complete.
So far in the lab, you've
created a configuration.
You specified some values
in the vm.yaml file,
such as your project ID
and the VM image to deploy.
To deploy the configuration,
you run this gcloud command.
You will see the status
of your configuration
while it's being deployed.
Upon completion, you will see
the state change to complete.
You can then view information
about the deployment
by running the describe command.
Using the manifest ID
output in the last command,
you can see your
deployments manifest.
Well, there we have it.
Let us know how you
use Deployment Manager.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Don't forget to keep
visiting our OnAir webinar
series, our Qwiklabs,
and our blogs.
All the links are below.
HEATHER CROSS:
You can also learn
more about Deployment Manager
through our on-demand courses
on Coursera.
Thanks for watching,
and we'll see you soon.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: See you.
HEATHER CROSS: Check out
our last episode, where
we take a look at Stackdriver.
We meet with Morgan,
the product manager,
to discuss monitoring, error
reporting, and de-bugging.